[Music]
oh yeah best friendship ever
welcome back everyone this is my full
rick and morty season 5 episode 8 video
the welcome back bird person episode
there's so many mind blowers and big
reveals about rick's history the truth
of rick's history so we'll break it all
down if you're brand new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the
episodes there's a bunch of really big
stuff happening this week too and also
talk about the finale because they
changed the schedule because of what
they're doing with the finale it's going
to be a full hour long i'm still doing
the giveaway for rick and morty merch
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your favorite big
reveal or easter egg or reference from
the episode on the video careful for
spoilers from the entire episode if you
haven't seen it yet i'll number these
easter eggs and wtf moments as we go
along to stay organized starting with
the episode title ricternal friendshine
of the spotless mort which is a
reference to the movie eternal sunshine
of the spotless mind during that movie
jim carrey is trying to get over a
breakup with his girlfriend kate winslet
he signs up for a service that's going
to remove her from his memories
literally but while it's happening he
changes his mind deciding that he loves
her and tries to save his memory of her
with the two of them running through
different memories of his trying to keep
the memory of her alive during the
episode a version of bird person
attempts to destroy himself literally
blow his mind from the inside out and as
the reality of his memories start to
crumble around him his mind starts to
crumble the ricks are running around
trying to save him they're like the jim
carreys running around in eternal
sunshine for bird person though the
thing that makes him change his mind and
want to live to save himself is learning
that he has a secret half bird person
child with tammy that's alive in the
real world being held captive on an
asteroid prison by the remnants of the
galactic federation that's obviously
something that they'll have to cover in
a future episode so i'll address that
when we get to that part of the video
but that's only one thing on a long list
of big mind blowers that they reveal
about rick's history mines were being
blown metaphorically and literally
during the episode and one of the
devices that they used to escape was
from the morty's mind blowers episode
but the actual episode starts with the
rest of the family going on a cruise
leaving rick by himself at the house
beth kind of joking about a lot of
movies where they leave kids on by
themselves without parental supervision
rick makes a pickle rick reference
claiming the minute they leave the
chance of his ego swelling out of
control him attempting another pickle
rick scenario shoots through the roof
which it kind of does he doesn't turn
himself into a pickle but he does turn
himself into pure thought to enter bird
person's mind the entire episode is full
of references like this to earlier
episodes as well as revealing older
events in rick's life that he and bird
person only talked about during season
one and season two like the battle of
blood ridge we also get to see them
forming their band flesh curtains for
the first time just the whole episode is
full of nuggets like this so he finally
brings phoenix person out of storage
where he's been since the end of season
4 with him inside the compartment in his
garage and proceeds to get into it with
the ai of his garage who offers to suck
his and their neighbor's jeans dicks
multiple times jean is getting a whole
lot of play this season not only did
they reference him last week rick also
ran over him with the car during episode
4 when morty's mutant sperm were killing
everyone he removes all bird person's
cybernetic enhancements so that he looks
a little bit more like himself he does
have a bunch of extra scarves from his
original death and all the surgery that
the federation performed on him the
reason why the ai has the anxiety attack
and starts stalling for time is just
because it isn't able to fix bird person
the way that rick wants him to be fixed
and she's afraid that rick is going to
terminate her program which is when she
starts waffling and offering to suck him
off the whole idea that she's terrified
of dying the ai is terrified of dying is
also meant to be a parallel for bird
person wanting to die then deciding that
he does not want to die during the
episode they said at the whole eternal
sunshine plot by saying that bird person
hid his original mind deep inside his
own memories to protect it from the
galactic federation when they turned him
into phoenix person the reason why rick
doesn't take the ai up on his suggestion
to just hop to a different timeline or
different universe where bird person is
fine and steal another version of him is
because he wants to restore the version
of bird person who he grew up with his
original bird person later in the
episode a younger version of him at
bloodridge also tries to float this same
idea to a younger bird person after
their battle like look nothing matters
infinite realities let's go have
adventures so when rick tells his ai
that he's not going to do that it's his
way of saying that he's matured since
blood rich he's admitting to himself
that some things do matter bird person
matters to him and he also kind of
confesses this to the memory of his
younger self later in the episode that
they love their friend bird person even
though his younger self isn't ready to
admit that yet when he's loading up the
process to convert himself into a
thought that's the pickle rick moment of
the episode you see he's got a sentient
energy-based creature trapped in the
wall melting it down to power the
process it's the same creature that he's
smoking at their sci-fi version of
burning man later in the episode they
said at the whole joke with the garage
ai trying to get gene's help with the
batteries because rick explains that if
something does go wrong and he dies
while inside bird person's mind the ai
battery only lasts for 600 years the ai
freaking out so badly when things look
like they're going off the rails
thinking that it might die that it tries
to wrangle in gene's help by offering to
suck him off and using the marvel movies
there's so many marvel references this
season i've already talked about in the
previous episode videos a lot of former
rick and morty writers are now working
on new marvel movies in marvel disney
plus series like the loki show runner
was a former rick and morty writer he
also wrote the doctor strange 2
multiverse of madness movie one of the
other writers who wrote the pickle rick
episode which they referenced during
this episode is actually working on the
marvel disney plus she-hulk series dan
harmon himself made a joke about how
marvel is stealing a bunch of his
writers but he said it in jess like he's
not upset about it the marvel reference
here though is gene is like oh you're
kind of like a version of jarvis and
when the ai says haha i wish that's just
a reference to how much rick mistreats
her and abuses her rick starting out in
that giant bird skull is just meant to
be a representation of him entering bird
person's mind literally like he starts
out where the brain would be inside this
skull but the reason why it's ultra
stylized is in service of the charlie
kaufman joke that they pay off later
which is actually the second charlie
kaufman joke this season they made
another reference to him during the
thanksgiving turkey episode when jerry
was watching that really messed up
trippy version of a charlie kaufman
wizard of oz movie he also says with a
joke about him being naked because it's
so artsy which they then pay off
immediately when his clothes
disintegrate off of him him diving into
the hole is also a representation of him
traveling down into bird person's
deepest memories like he's diving into a
giant ocean of memory the egg that he
crashes through into the yoke is just a
reference to bird person's birth because
he's traveling forward through bird
person's memories like each new memory
that he travels to is further forward in
the timeline this is also meant to be a
reference to foreshadow the birth of
bird person's child with tammy later in
the episode all the trippy transitions
between the different memories is a
thing from eternal sunshine in that
movie the memories start to bleed
together so they cut between the scenes
with really trippy transitions like this
the next memory rick goes to is a
version of an intergalactic burning man
mixed with lollapalooza they call it
burning man a palooza flargabarg this is
meant to be the moment where he met bird
person for the first time because this
rick has the same clothes and almost the
same haircut i'm assuming that not a ton
of time passes between this and the
events of blood ridge so we'll say rick
was already approaching his mid-30s when
this was happening because he's about 35
when blood ridge happens he meets bird
person who apparently also loves to
party they get high together bird person
explains that he's called bird person
because his culture doesn't believe in
names that's the writers joking about
how in real life they were kind of lazy
when they first created the bird person
character like well he's a bird and he's
a person so we'll call him bird person
his actual first appearance was in
season 1 episode 11 when he shows up at
the house party saying the beacon was
activated there's a cool call back to
that during the episode when they break
up at blood ridge bird person says if
you ever need me activate the beacon so
the house party was the first time that
he activated the beacon a couple years
ago dan harmon revealed that bird person
is meant to be a parody of the sorceress
from he-man and the masters of the
universe because she wears the bird
costume all the time and changes into a
bird rick takes the porta potty into the
next memory of them together and it's
them on a mission with rick trying to
get revenge against the citadel of rix
for the death of his wife diane if you
couldn't tell that's basically what's
happening here that's why they say
killing us won't bring her back so this
is actually a really big deal it's one
of the big truth bombs that they drop
about rick's history during the episode
because remember these are bird persons
memories so you know that the events
really happened earlier this season mr
nimbus confirmed that rick's wife died a
long time ago and during season 3
episode 1 he showed us a memory of the
citadel of rix murdering her in order to
get rid of rick's family so that he
would be more willing to join them but
at the time rick claimed that that
memory was false or could be false so we
couldn't really trust it as fans whether
or not the citadel of ricks really were
behind the death of his family later in
the episode they seemingly back this
idea up that that memory was real when
they reveal that beth has been a clone
this whole time that's what younger rick
meant when he said you've been living
with a version of your dead daughter
implying that this whole memory of them
dying in this explosion was actually
real this whole time that felt like an
even bigger reveal than bird person's
child during the episode but then he
travels to the next memory which is then
planning the battle a blood ridge and we
meet his original crew some of them were
referenced in previous episodes like
bird person squanchy we know still
wondering where he is in present day
squanchy is still alive until confirmed
otherwise this is geared dude he's the
older brother of gearhead from previous
seasons we also see a younger version of
gearhead inside the memory of gear
dude's funeral when they run him over
poor old gearhead he just can't catch a
break as far as i know they don't give
names to these other three crew members
here but maybe we'll find out about them
some other way the younger 35 year old
memory version of rick discovers c137
who wins him over after revealing that
he's a memory wait a minute why was my
ninth birthday party in a pine tree it's
just because bird person wasn't there
for rick's ninth birthday party so he
has no idea what happened during that
they kind of use this to set up the
whole logic for how the memories work
and give you the rules the memory
versions can't use their portal guns for
instance because bird person never
understood where they were using the
portals to travel to also setting up the
twists later that they can only use
technology of ricks that per person
remembers and understands you also
notice this younger version of rick is
carrying around a much more primitive
version of his portal gun they both make
a joke about no one having true free
will that was actually a pretty big
thing during the loki finale the loki
series was done like i said by one of
the former writers on rick and morty the
whole premise of the loki series though
was that the only person in the universe
who had true free will or the multiverse
if you want to think about it that way
was a version of kang called he who
remains who was controlling the entire
timeline so we'll see if we have a
similar payoff on rick and morty with
someone secretly orchestrating events on
a multiversal scale and here we go again
with all the evil morty theories then
they travel to the next memory where
they finally find the real bird person
watching a memory of his from a time
earlier in his relationship with tammy
they do the same gross tammy joke from
back in season one with her talking
about sucking him off and the real bird
person whispering the line don't be
gross tammy kind of crying a little bit
whole lot of blow jobs going around in
this episode between tammy and the
garage ai they chase him to the next
memory which is after the federation
attacked his planet you notice the
building here in the background says
historic childhood trauma town as the
federation captures a bunch of bird
persons people memory rick comes back
and jokes about not understanding the
rules of the episode am i invincible can
we both die in here are we damaging bird
person's brain by messing around with
everything just calling out the logic of
the whole episode not totally making
sense then sort of flipping that on its
head by using his fake portal gun which
doesn't work as a shield they make fun
of the shrek movies younger rick saying
he's just a grumpy ogre and they made
four of them and rick joking that
there's probably a fifth shrek movie in
the time that they've been doing this
during the episode morty is also a super
fan of the shrek movies they said of the
whole idea of younger rick hating the
idea of older rick when he has to
explain who morty is and what his life
is like how he's living with the version
of beth and like i said that's when they
reveal the best that we've been seeing
this whole time has actually been a beth
from an alternate reality that's what he
meant when he said you're one of those
creepy versions of rick that just moves
in with abandoned bess so if we're
assuming that this season three episode
one memory of them actually did happen
it is a true memory he creates his first
portal gun and then at some point after
this he gets his revenge against the
citadel that we see play out in that
earlier memory from the episode then at
some point after that he would have
found an alternate reality where there
was a version of beth who didn't wind up
dying during this accident that we see
during season three episode one and
would have just moved in with her
pretending to be her version of rick
a play over your own daughter yes i am
beth because you're not my own daughter
later rick makes another space beth
reference telling bird person at the end
of the episode that he shouldn't create
a clone of his new kid and then send it
into space because apparently they hate
that then they travel to the next memory
which is inside the place where the
federation brought him back as phoenix
person and mess with his mind he tells
the younger version of himself to go
look for secret intel on the federation
they don't really reference that again
but because the memory version of rick
survives escaping into one of rick's
real memories he's just gonna keep on
living in there real c-137 rick now has
access to new intel on the federation
that he acquired he just needs to go
back to the memory of his childhood
bedroom to find that version of rick and
ask him for that information all the
bombs that bird person is making to blow
his own mind metaphorically and
literally are created using energy from
his negative emotions like the negative
aspects of his mind his rage one of them
is cringe one is denial blame fear
trauma depression disdain so it's a
metaphor for bird person metaphorically
and literally melting down like you talk
about people in real life having
meltdowns having mental breakdowns this
is like a literal representation of that
rick makes a scientology joke claiming
that he get in a sauna with john
travolta to save bird person as younger
rick tries to find them he starts going
around opening doors to different
memories this one is from their death at
the wedding in season two also allowing
this version of tammy to escape and
chase them down later in the episode
both of the ricks then learn about the
existence of a bird person's child in
another memory which is also set up for
that ending where bird person calls him
out for not telling him about the babies
sooner rick makes a blue man group when
talking about getting your mind blown
because they're metaphorically and
literally blowing bird person's mind
during the episode then they traveled to
bird person's memory of their fight from
the end of season 4 when he was still
phoenix person just to steal the clothes
off of this rick's back i love the way
this version of rick also reacts that i
always knew that this was the way i
would die we'll see if they pay that off
during the final rick and morty episode
whatever the final season winds up being
then as the reality a bird person's mind
starts to crumble around them they take
a shortcut by traveling through bird
persons ptsd represented by the subway
train which takes them to the memory of
the battle of blood ridge the actual
battle of bloodridge is an amazing
action set piece it must have taken them
a long time to animate this and the
younger version of rick is sort of a
surrogate for the audience like oh my
god this is so cool i can't believe this
the giant walkers do kind of seem like
star wars atats and atsds but i actually
think that they're meant to be a
different sci-fi movie reference so if
you think you know what these designs
are based on just write it below in the
comments but the real reason why it's
such a major event in rick's life isn't
because it was a huge battle which it
was it's because it was sort of the
moment of the end of his friendship with
bird person even though it wasn't the
actual end of their friendship they
basically broke up so to speak they made
all these references to them having this
really bloody war and them potentially
losing the battle so the idea was they
didn't actually lose the battle against
the federation they beat the federation
but rick still feels like they lost the
battle because he lost the battle for
his friend then they travel to the next
memory which is a bird person in tammy
in the way the bird person explains it
he knew that he was getting ready to die
like he was about to die at any moment
and wanted to die with the person that
he loved so he went to find a version of
tammy on a really nice day at their
house young rick makes a lincoln
memorial joke if you remember a couple
episodes ago in the thanksgiving episode
the lincoln memorial in the rick and
morty multiverse is the secret entrance
to the us government's vault where they
keep the aliens who are basically
responsible for all technology and
culture in the world rick calls out all
the tropes of the episode saying that
the closer the bird person's mind gets
to collapsing the more cannon bull crap
is going to come and try and kill them
which sets up tammy's joke revealing
that she is secretly a member of the
federation when rick says everybody
knows that's just a matter of reference
to us the viewers having learned about
that a couple years ago rick tells bird
person about his child to get him to
want to live tammy then reveals what
they would have done with the child had
there been one sort of setting up the
post-credits scene then they travel back
to bird person's memory meeting tammy
for the first time at rick's party
during season one when they teleported
the house to another reality making out
on his workbench which apparently is
gross but rick doesn't think that
squanchy jerking off in his closet is
gross because apparently some closets
are just for doing that meaning rick has
probably done that a lot in closets bird
person also apparently remembers the
plumbus from interdimensional cable them
just wanting to bring deep cuts easter
eggs back from previous episodes then
they get attacked by other memory
versions of phoenix person and tammy who
hates rick for making her spend two
years in high school just for reference
for people that don't live in the united
states high school for people in the u.s
is four years so she got off easy only
having to do two of those the gun
converts memories into energy which he
also then can use the same way that he
uses his portal gun fluid using it to
open portals to other memories allowing
them to escape i'm also sure that
they're going to be selling a lot of
this stuff in the episode that you see
as toys so like the guns the ships the
vehicles everything then they travel to
the memory of girdu's funeral where we
see young gearhead who they run over and
then when they're figuring out where to
travel next he mentions squanchy had a
very distasteful eulogy bird person
suggests they travel to squanchy's
terrible stand-up phase the bird
flappers comedy club name is just a
reference to the flappers comedy club
which is a real comedy club in hollywood
this version of rick here getting pissed
because he wasted his time realizing
that none of this was real when they
travel back to the original memory for
the burning man concert where they met
for the first time we see them forming
their band flesh curtains for the first
time there was also a reference to the
flesh curtains band during episode 5
earlier this season in the dive bar
someone graffitiing that their band
sucked and someone else crossing that
out saying that they really sucked there
was also a squanchy reference on the
wall of that bar too young rick
sacrifices himself to save them from the
tammy from the memory of their wedding
later we find out he somehow found a way
to escape into real rick's mind and the
whole animation of the black ooze bird
monster here consuming the rest of the
memories actually feels kind of like a
princess mononoke reference deep cut it
also kind of reminds me of the pollution
monster from fern gully for anyone that
saw that other old animated movie they
pulled that whole joke with bird person
speaking like rick and then revealing
that it was rick because bird person
normally speaks in that very formal way
then he ports his mind back to his body
rick makes the same hundred years
reference from earlier in the series
rick and bird person a hundred years he
makes the space beth reference again and
then bird person calls him out for
withholding the information about his
child in they mutually part ways like i
said i think the whole vibe here is that
the writers are telling us that they're
gonna bring bird person back eventually
and they'll pay off his child in a
future episode like rick will probably
agree to help bird person rescue his
child and they'll just handle that in
some future season they pay off that
joke about the ai blowing gene and then
they explain where the younger rick went
to hide inside rick's memories he
traveled into one of rick's earlier
memories from his own childhood so you
see posters and schematics for his
spaceship you see a console that he's
modifying gears on his dresser just
generally references to all the
adventures that he will have someday as
an adult the whole joke with the
babysitter is that she's getting super
naked in the living room and he just
runs out to take a peek so the joke here
is that young rick traveled back to hyde
in a very fap-worthy fantasy moment from
his earlier childhood that's why he
smiles knowingly when little rick runs
out to take a peek at the babysitter all
naked and then tries to follow him too
to also catch the naked babysitter again
older rick catching him in the act
knowing exactly what he was doing the
whole time i also love the joke where he
offers to make him a real person so that
they can have a drink together but the
young rick still hates the idea of
turning into the old rick so much that
he's like you know what i'm gonna pass
on that why don't i just stay in here
and you remember having a drake with me
also another huge reveal here so if you
look at the wall this is a big deal this
is a picture of rick's parents i think
this is the first time we've ever seen
rick's parents depicted on the series
maybe we'll see some more easter eggs
for them in future seasons then during
the post-credits scene they pay off bird
person's child who looks kind of like a
little tammy with wings basically in
bird person's eyes being held captive in
a federation prison they get into a
fight at super hardcore and it actually
feels like this is meant to be a
reference to star trek deep space nine
there was a season of that show where
wharf and a couple of the bigger side
characters were trapped in a secret
dominion prison on a remote asteroid for
a long period of time and none of their
friends knew that they were there they
had to escape so like i said some future
episodes they'll probably pay this off
having rick help bird person rescue his
child if you did spot any easter eggs in
the episode that i didn't mention in the
video just write them below in the
comments i have to say this is probably
one of my favorite episodes from the
season so far like i said the finale
won't be till september 5th but episode
9 will be a full hour long so it's
basically like two episodes jammed
together big reminder too this week
marvel's what if episodes are starting
my full episode 1 video will post
wednesday it'll be the exact same
schedule as my loki episode videos what
if will also be canon to the mcu the
movies and the other live action disney
plus series i will try to do a rick and
morty finale trailer video i'll name a
giveaway winner when i post that video
everyone click here for my full suicide
squad post credit scene video and click
here for my marvel what if episode 1
trailer video and i'll replace the link
with my full episode 1 video after i
post later this week thank you so much
for watching everyone stay safe and i'll
see you in the next video
[Music]